[Music]
we can begin the next front in our war
which we're calling opening up America
again we must have a working economy and
we want to get it back very very quickly
and that's what's going to happen I
believe it will boom all right that was
the president obviously he was preparing
the nation for the next front in this
war against cope in nineteen and as the
White House releases their guidelines
for States to reopen carefully that is
and in three separate phases the
coronavirus task force will be coming
out again in an hour from now for their
Friday update so in the meantime we will
break it all down first of all the first
phase could see the reopening of Jim's
restaurants movie theaters and sport
venues but with strict social distancing
measures in place schools would stay
closed and high risk individuals would
stay home the other phases would then
loosen restrictions more if cases
continue to fall but there are some
critics of the plan including Speaker
Nancy Pelosi calling those guidelines
quote vague and inconsistent and here's
more reaction from other Democrats I
think what he's done he's kind of punted
he's decided that he's not he doesn't
have the right to make the call for the
country you have to know who has the
illness who's immune from the illness
and who can who could get the illness
before we can determine who can go back
to work okay it's up to the states but
then don't ask the states don't give
them this massive undertaking that has
never been done before
and then not give them any resources to
do it
alright happy Friday
Greg I wanted to start with you I
thought I'd give a little perspective
just to set this up because in a way all
of us sort of feel like it's Groundhog
Day it's been about four weeks now that
we've been doing the show remote at
least I have from here and last Friday
was the end of the week of which Jerome
Adams the Surgeon General had said this
is going to be our Pearl Harbor a moment
that was when we had hopefully reaching
the apex
the peak this week we're talking about
the reopening and we have some guidance
some of it is vague because the states
are going to have to decide based on
their different criteria but isn't that
a little bit of a hopeful sign that it's
not just one big blob that we actually
can look at some progress here yeah I
don't see anything here that is vague I
see a roadmap and you're allowed to
drive it what drives me crazy is that if
Trump had taken more command over this
and said this is what you're going to do
they would have accused him of being
autocratic a dictator and a tyrant so
what does he do he shares the
responsibility with the governor's he
says here's the road map you drive the
car and now he's accused of punting by
Joe Biden are you serious it is so
pathetic and then I predicted this
yesterday I said that Pelosi wasn't
gonna say anything until after the plan
is revealed because she didn't want any
skin in this game she preferred to get
stand in front of her double-wide
refrigerator and sucked down ice-cream
until she gets an ice-cream headache
did it actually beep rat beep offer
practical advice you know you can sit on
a fence and you could you know crap on
people doing the job when you're out of
power that makes sense but at this point
it's just so obvious and so sad in this
situation people's lives are gonna
there's gonna be death because every
path that we choose is going to have
death so the path that you have to
choose is a road map in which you can go
in Reverse or you can pause or you can
take a left or a right that's what this
is you are a state you are a sports car
with a stick shift
and you shift gears based on the terrain
that's coming at you and you can even go
and reverse that's what this guideline
is so to sit there and go like oh it's
vague and inconsistent you're just an
idiot pure and simple
stick to your ice cream of course Pelosi
and then I think that we have a couple
of trunk tweets today and then a Cuomo
soundbite if you could pull up those
Trump tweets so I could read those for
folks who are maybe listening on the
radio so President Trump tweeted this
morning the Governor Cuomo should spend
more time doing and less time
complaining get out there and get the
job done stop
we built you thousands of hospital beds
that you didn't need or use gave large
numbers of ventilators that you should
have had and helped you with let's see
there's a little bit more testing that
you should be doing we have given New
York far more money help and equipment
than any other state by far and these
great men and women who did the job
never hear you say thanks your numbers
are not good less talk and more action I
think he does say thank you a lot quite
a bit to the health care workers but
Governor Cuomo decided to respond we
have a soundbite of that let's listen
first of all if he's sitting home
watching TV maybe he should get up and
go to work right
second the let's keep emotion and
politics out of this and personal ego if
we can because this is about the people
and it's about our job and let's try to
focus on that all right one I'll let you
take a whack at this one well you know I
hate to see us get political about this
I mean I think we need to work together
and I would hope that you know sometimes
the president loves to be celebrated and
thanked and all that okay so Cuomo then
fires back I do not sure it takes as
much of anywhere but I will say this in
terms of the plan Dana to me I feel like
everybody's got cabin fever we know
about the high unemployment numbers
everybody wants to get out get back to
work but we have to be careful we can't
let sort of emotions that you know drive
as impatience because if we don't have
testing if we don't have contact tracing
then we could get ourselves in a very
difficult situation where we put our
workers the people going back to work at
a very high level of risk and we put all
their customers the people they come
into contact with work with also at risk
and then we could find ourselves in a
worse situation so I think when you hear
people say we'd like to know how to deal
with that and we'd like the federal
government's help I think in terms of
specifics what Schumer was talking about
even what you heard from Governor Cuomo
in terms of okay if you lay out a plan
give us some of the resources to
make it work I think that's what people
are saying I don't think it has to
necessarily become sort of something
nasty and divisive and finger-pointing
got it and actually Katie I thought
there were lots of different governors
on the greg's laughing but I'll just
keep going but lots of different
governors on the shows today talking
about how they are working in
coordination with the federal government
and they're trying to figure out their
own roadmap so there was a Colorado
governor the Alaska governor Ohio and
all of these states have a little bit of
a different situation on their hands
which exists exactly why the president
has said it's up to you guys to do what
you want with this plan it's going to be
in phases different places with lower
density populations are going to have a
different project and process moving
forward on this but it's interesting to
watch what's happening here in DC or not
in DC where lawmakers are at home you
have Chuck Schumer and an see Pelosi
criticizing this plan and continually
saying that you have to be careful you
have to make sure the economy isn't open
too quickly well when they're sitting
there at home and not refilling the
paycheck Protection Plan with a program
and not coming up with any other ideas
or how to get people some economic help
while they continue to advocate for the
economy to be closed it's really easy to
do that and it's also easy to do it when
you're getting a paycheck and the bottom
line anything for people who are getting
cabin fever as Juan said is they want to
be able to make their own decisions
about their own risk at this point they
understand a lot more about the virus
than when you did two months ago and
they understand what precautions they
need to take to not get sick but they
really want to be able to do that on
their own without being dictated to by
the government all right Jesse let me
give you the last word here well I mean
if Democrats have a problem with the
plan take it up with foul Chi and Burkes
they're the experts that signed off on
it and then there's Cuomo everybody on
the left loves them they want him to run
for president so President Trump gives
him free power and they say oh he can't
handle it he can't do it by himself all
of a sudden Cuomo is complaining about
not getting the resources he just
donated hundreds of ventilators to other
states because he had over capacity
because the president gave
so many they just built a hospital in
Long Island they haven't even used it
yet so I would stop complaining already
before the Presidents even given you any
additional resources this country is
viewing this from two different
perspectives there's people that are
better off that they're kind of having a
little fun maybe working from home
they're still getting paid they're
zooming you know they're doing their
thing they're cooking and then there's
people that can't afford to work from
home they don't have a job they've lost
a business which been in their family
for generations and they're dying to get
back to work and one side doesn't
understand the other side you know how
could you not want to protect the health
well what about if the spreads further
and then the other side is saying wait a
second you guys understanding my
position I need to work to feed my
family or else this is it for me and
they're talking across of each other and
a lot of it has to do with New York the
state of New York has 225,000 cases New
Jersey has 75,000 cases
combined that's 300,000 virus cases the
next biggest state that has a case is
like 30,000 Massachusetts other states
like Wyoming North Dakota Hawaii Vermont
West Virginia they have a couple hundred
cases and so to say that New York should
open up at the same rate as Vermont
which has like a handful of cases is
stupid everybody knows that stupid but
they're trying to attack the president
for politics and that's just wrong